in case you don't know datatonic we are
consulting firms specializing all things
data and google cloud to work
exclusively on google cloud platform
where we work in industries such as
media telco
and broadcasting
and help clients establish best
practices data platforms but also unlock
potential of machine learning use cases
together with them
and i'll give you a bit an example of
the type of work later
so i want to start with a question
and that is why
moving machine learning models into
production is so hard
because the perception is that it's just
about building training a model and
having that modern instrument instance
in inference
but the reality of ai workloads is much
more diverse
there is
considerations our data ingestion around
versioning of the model maybe also the
inference server there's points to take
care of around retraining and around
updating your models you might want to
monitor your data you might want to
monitor
the model performance and of course
security or extensibility towards ap
testing is also important
all these tasks are
being called envelopes over the past few
years and it's a very interesting and
evolving field but it brings a lot of
the points and
workflows from normal software
engineering into the machine learning
world
to really achieve some of the aspects
and cover the bases on mlops there's a
few ways to go forward i want to start
quite simple with a way to establish
machinery and pipeline that picks up
some of these boxes on the right hand
side here
but i also then want to
expand a little bit on this and see how
this can be taken further
so let's start with a simple view
it's a simple view on ml ops we can call
this more tactical and it's probably
something you're quite familiar with if
you date a scientist
so you start with some offline data
and you then go through some steps of
data extraction
and then there could be a few elements
of manual experimentation in mobile
build so this data preparation small
training and you might evaluate this
what you'll get is a trained model
instance
and in an easy way to achieve some
operationability and serve this model to
users or
customers of your own business you
export this to a model registry
and this is then where the operations
site can plug in and take this model
registry and build an inference server
to serve predictions it could just be a
little flask instance for example
so this is very manual process
through the model development but also
the operations are quite limited and
we'll just pick up the model once it's
ready
how you want to expand on this is to
achieve a much more transformational
view and really take
these points i made on the previous
slide into account
so to
develop machine learning mods as you
would develop normal software you want
to bring in a lot more automation and
monitoring and one way to expand on this
is for example the model build itself
before there was very manual step by
step now we actually can
have a automated pipeline that does data
extraction up until an exported and
trained model
but you also want to bring in some
elements of data validation for example
model validation
and when you're ready and happy with the
model you can bless this and still
export this to a model register
now here it won't just get built into an
infant server but it will actually get
tied into a whole cicd pipeline that you
see on the right hand side so you can
deal with packages different model
versions or different versions of
inference
serving capabilities as well
and at the end you get your prediction
service
reaching your customers and your
business
on top of that prediction service you
would like to
pay close attention to the monitoring
this is monitoring of the service
performance overall
availability and uptime but also of the
model accuracy
you can use this to really guide updates
to the model as it is and as the machine
learning and ai solution performs so if
you notice some degradation you can
maybe trigger an update of the model
build or trigger updates to the feature
store if that's not sufficient you might
want to consider going all the way back
up here to where the data is and where
you do data analysis
and this might entice an orchestration
experimental environment where you can
conceptualize and build new models as a
whole and do some model analysis and
where you treat the model not as safe
training instances by their source code
so this is really the the visual we want
to go to and we work with a lot of
clients to achieve
but as i said let's start simple and
look at some of the tool sets to do this
serverless in the cloud
and for that i'd like to highlight the
case study
and the case study is
with a client we work with in the uk
this is lush glass cosmetics
if you're not familiar with lost
cosmetics the global retailer selling
cosmetics
products and are mostly famous for these
bath bombs you see on the picture here
their
products are handmade and lush is on a
journey to become much more
environmentally friendly and one big
step towards achieving that is reduce it
reducing plastics packaging in their
stores
so removing plastics
and packaging
in their stores is obviously
great on first thought but it comes with
some
complexity and challenges as well
so now you might walk into the last
store and you see products on the
shelves not in plastic or not in
packaging with information and label but
more stacked as you would see groceries
stack fruit and lose vegetables
issue with this is that you don't have
label information on each of the
products themselves anymore and that's
particularly
a concern for cosmetics where people are
curious
about the ingredients and
that they might have concerns about
allergens for example because they put
these products on on their skin
so in order to still provide the
relevant information about the product
it could be the
ingredients but it cost me the name and
the price to the customers lush came up
with an idea of creating a digital label
in a phone app
so what does that mean the idea here is
that
you would take your phone either at home
or in store and take a picture with the
phone camera of a product and through
that
even although there's no packaging on a
no label
the phone can recognize the product
through computer vision and pull in all
the information that you need as a
consumer so this could be the price the
name and the
ingredients and where to buy the product
again if you really like it and you have
it at home
so this is great and it relies on
machine learning and compute division to
find
identify the relevant product and then
pull in that information
when we started working with lush they
already had a prototype of this running
and
the prototype was available on ios only
because they built this on ios core ml
and the performance unfortunately just
hit the miss so we start working with
large to improve the performance of this
image classifier of their
cosmetics products
and also to bring the
technology to android
phones at the same time and build a
process that allows lush to update the
machine learning model whenever they
have new products
so as a company they develop new
products on a weekly basis
which means whenever there's new
products in their catalog they would
need a new machine learning model so it
can recognize all products correctly
for that we work on a pipeline together
so it makes it easy for their developers
and these are app developers not
necessary data scientists to update
the
lush lens app and really have the latest
products built in and able to recognize
so let's start with the model
for the model we use tensorflow
and we used the python api in tensorflow
and we realized we need some performant
image classifier that also works well on
a mobile phone where computational power
is limited and storage space is small
so we choose as a base model mobile net
version 2. we also use tensorflow
because we knew we can use its
portability layer called tensorflow lite
to export the model and bring it to ios
and android at the same time
and
this was a key consideration to really
reach the whole user base uh for lush on
their mobile devices and also have the
opportunity to have in-store devices
available for the customers
so to build now a good image classifier
we spent a lot of research and time on
building on top of this mobile net
version to architecture and training the
model
the first time i think our computer
vision pretty solved use case but this
was particularly difficult here because
all the last products look very similar
so we're not trying to classify a chair
versus a car but we actually classifying
very similar bath bombs they're all
round they're all about the same size
and shape
so that's the challenge second i
mentioned that the products are handmade
this means
they all have the defects there is
variance in
how the surfaces look like the texture
and the color so an additional challenge
here is as well and lastly lighting
conditions can be very different
depending on the store but also your
home environment so it could take care
of that as well
to really solve this achieve great
classification performance we did a lot
of data augmentation and changed things
like saturation and crops
of the images itself
this worked really well we then did
transfer learning on top of the base v
newton architecture of mobilenet but
also did some some changes in rewiring
the last layers and then extensive
hybrid tuning really yielded a model
performance there was a massive
improvement
so we improved the f1 score from 45
percent initially to 97 so now we had a
model
that really reliably could recognize all
their products
this is great now we want to build this
into a serverless machine learning
pipeline
and we have to take care of a few things
we want to pre-process the images
we want to automate the training
we want to have some element of
monitoring
and some way of storing and versioning
old models as well
so these are really these envelopes
tasks i
started off in highlighting in this
session
so at the big picture
the pipeline looks like this there's an
image upload and as i said we work on
google cloud here so we load this to
google cloud storage and there's a big
box of data preparation
followed by a box of machine learning
and the dlct of live model that we can
then bring to is or android
so let's dive into these aspects or
these different boxes
and we start with data preparation
so whenever lush has a new product they
will add a new folder to google cloud
storage for the new product with around
50 30 to 50 new images describing this
product as training material
and we then kick off a process in apache
beam run on google cloud's data flow to
convert these images from jpeg to tf
records
more than in a minute
we can then store training and
evaluation data in google cloud storage
and start a process of data augmentation
that will write in
tensorflow and they will execute on
google cloud's ai platform as a
serverless process so this data
augmentation does things like flipping
saturation changes crops etc
let's have a further look in conversion
of the jpeg images to tf records
this is done because df records is
tensorflow's preferred way of
storing training
also actually evaluation data and it
allows a lot more throughput
than
just loading
small files small size jpeg images
this pipeline was written in apache b
which has a python api and actually is a
really versatile data processing
framework and you can run and execute
the job serverless in data flow
when written as a beam pipeline and this
works on different types of runners such
as sparks
execution engine as well
and we really allowed us here to go
through 50 000 jpegs in around 10
minutes
the python api
also in beam allows for streaming and
batch
pipelines so you can actually have a
unified api and write a pipeline that
works in both scenarios but here we
obviously only limited ourselves to
batch
so how does a beam pipeline look like i
just want to give you a piece of code
here that
describes the concepts a little bit
this is not working code by the way i
just want to highlight a few aspects
so crucially you might have a processing
function that does some work and here
the work is converting a jpeg into tf
record so we write this convert function
here use tensorflow to create an example
and then later on write this as a tf
record and serialize it in that way
but the pipeline itself is an
interesting object and that's defined
down here
it takes in some options
and the options are useful here to
describe to the data flow service what
we're actually trying to do and give
some names etc
let's have a look at the pipeline itself
we can use the beam io to read
we then use a flat map to apply this
conversion on each of the files in
parallel so this scales really well and
runs on distributed architectures as
well if needed
and then lastly we can write again in
parallel to shorts and tf records so
that's just a few steps and you see the
python sdk here uses pipe
operator and simple to define
beam pipeline that can then be executed
so this is great we now got the training
images ready
so let's do some actual model training
on our defined model that we established
before again we use ar platform that
executes tensorflow.job serverless to do
training and evaluation
we then store some metrics and push them
into bigquery google cloud
serverless data warehouse
and if we're happy with the model
performance we go further and actually
export the model to tf light again in
our platform and then store it in google
cloud storage if for some reason the
model performance would degrade
for example bad training images lush
adds a new product that throws out the
training process for some reason
we actually won't go ahead with the
export but we stop
at this stage where
we look at the
automatically look at the metrics and if
they don't pass the threshold we don't
move on
so this training evaluation job is done
in a platform and it runs the same
python tensorflow code that we run on my
laptop but runs it on distributed
ways you can attach gpus and tpus and we
do the conversion to tf live here as
well
to reduce the size and make it really
easy to deploy and load on phones and
also very fast inference we actually
pull a few tricks uh most importantly
integer quantization
and it yields a really
good image classifier of only three and
a half megabyte size roughly
the evaluation step here
happens
after the training on evaluation data
and then exports some metrics into
bigquery as i described
just want to give you a look at this
here
it's very simple we just for each run
log
some of the metrics we are after it
could be accuracy or the f1 score and as
i said if we pass a certain threshold we
can then
trigger the export
so let's put this all together
we discuss both key elements on data
prep and machine learning in detail and
they fit together like this in this
picture so whenever lush uploads a new
whole folder with a new product
that contains training images for that
to gcs we'll trigger all these steps we
we looked at the conversion to tf
records
we then do the data augmentation in our
platform
followed by training and
storing the metrics
if all is thumbs up we go ahead and
export it and then push it back to gcs
where the last app developers can pick
up the model version as a tf live file
and bake it into their new released
mobile apps
so one thing is missing here in this
picture
it's not
missing in the picture i just haven't
talked about it but it's the aspect of
automation here at the top
so to really define all these tasks and
chain them together we use apache
airflow
uh it's managed service in google cloud
called
cloud composer
so if you're not familiar with airflow
it's a great tool to write out data more
pipelines in python and because it's all
python tasks
you can create very dynamic and
extensible workflows and it connects
super well with all gcp tools but
they're all cloud providers
it's really meant to scale out it's not
designed to do actual work as in data
processing work on the airflow instance
itself but it can leverage um cloud
services very well it is really where
you can shoot off the task to the data
flow iii platform and use the airflow
instance as the orchestrator while doing
all the heavy lifting on the services
that are designed to do so
it comes with a little ui that's very
useful to to managing the the dacs as
they're defined as in these workflows
and to monitor them as well
and we actually touched upon dags a lot
so dag is a directed a cyclic graph and
airflow uses that concept to define its
workflows as a series of tasks but we're
actually doing all
the things here with dax if you remember
a tensorflow
model graph is actually also dag and
a data flow pipeline is
also
actually an instance of a dag anyhow in
airflow we can define all the tasks and
conditions simply in python and in this
case we trigger
the stack the execution of the workflow
when a new folder is detected in gcs
so how does that look like
i'll give you a very brief example as
well
far from complete far from working but
we can just use airflow to build this
tag instance here as an object give it a
nice name
and then package the tasks in there so
we want to check for new files and
we can train a model
and we see we can do this with ml engine
or ar platform and just submit the
training job here and the job has
certain parameters
you can pass in for example things like
the batch size or we want to do the
export to tf5
and then we can also in this simplified
v here write the matrix to bq as another
python operator
and you see this is defining the whole
dag here a few tasks
and we're actually not
saying what each task is in detail or we
can just reference a python callable or
we can reference a file or a c code file
and this allows us also for neat
separation of developing this where all
this code can be built out separately
and then we use airflow to chain it all
together
lastly when we have this dag object we
can define the running order and also
the the all conditions on the workflow
if there should be branching or yes or
no go decisions etc and that's done here
at the bottom
so here we keep things very simple we
check for files we convert to tf records
we write out so it's just a simple
example to give you a flavor
of how an airflow deck can look like
so what we achieved
is we built a serverless pipeline on gcp
completely in python
we
have now
a compat
well-performing classifier that's
available for android and ios with a
huge improvement of performance
and if you want to give this a go and if
you like large products you can actually
download the lush labs app
and try this yourself in store
so really ticked off some considerations
of ml ops
such as orchestration
scalability and a little bit of model
governance
but of course we're still quite far off
this
transformational view that i mentioned
before so we started with this simple
tactical view so there's two tools hi
oliver yes sorry sorry to interact but
um
we are a little bit over bought now
because of the time in
so
yep um
i sent you a message of us about a chat
session yeah
all right so let me just wrap this up
yeah and yeah
then we can close this out so with this
transformational view there's two tools
that i highly recommend you to look into
to achieve this it's one cube flow and
that's two tensorflow extended
and with this i actually at the end as
well so i hope i could give you a flavor
on how you can use python to build these
custom analogues and our pipelines
and leverage some of the established
cloud tools
that really make this easy and
completely serverless but if you want to
go beyond this there's some other tools
that i would encourage you to look into
such as keyflow and tensorflow extend
so thank you very much and apologies for
the late start into this session
you